ihr wartet jetzt wahrscheinlich das
Minecraft mit Luca Intro und irgend eine
Begrüßung von mir die Sache ist
allerdings dass ich dafür gar keine Zeit
hatte weil ich direkt nach Verlassen des
Menüs in den Kampf geworfen wurde
[Musik]
ich wollte sagen es Salaam wann lieben
Freunde und
herzlich willkommen ihr heute zu einer
neuen Episode Minecraft mit Luca Staffel
2 wir befinden uns noch immer hier im
netter konntet ihr gerade unter daran
erkenn ich bin in meine Welt hier rein
gegangen und direkt greift mich ein Gas
an das Schwein stand ja auch noch hier
vorne ich nehme den Quarzwerke hier
vorne jetzt erstmal nicht mit weil ich
ja die
ich dachte diese grünen Punkte hier sein
Slimes gewesen ich nehme die quarzblöcke
hier vorne erstmal nicht mit weil ich
meine glücksspitzhacke noch nicht
besitze und damit wollte ich die ja
abbauen ich werde mich jetzt erstmal
darauf konzentrieren dass ich den Weg
hier zurück finde zu meinem Portal denn
ich glaube meine liebe Freundin der
Richtung das hat mir schon genug gezeigt
mit den ganzen Tieren die da rumlaufen
und den Gas dass ich da wahrscheinlich
nicht erfolgreich auf eine
wie komme ich
von hier
die ganze Zeit schon wieder älter
[Musik]
ich will einfach zurück zu meinem Portal
und diese Suche nach einer Festung
erstmal aufgeben ich brauche mich jetzt
einfach mal von hier vorne weg und gehe
hier in die Seite rein weil ich glaube
und das sehen wir ja oben rechts auf der
Minimap des wie irgendwie bei diesem
Lava Ding da waren und da irgendwo so
ein kleiner Weg war durch den wir
durchgelaufen sind wir müssten jetzt da
sein und hier ist auch der Weg wo wir
uns lang gebaut haben ich weiß zwar
nicht mehr ob wir uns hier irgendwie
hoch gebaut haben genau von hier kamen
wir auf jeden Fall und sind dann glaube
ich nicht ich habe gar keine Ahnung mehr
von
[Musik]
hier
ich glaube so
weiter
hey
das kannst du dir doch wirklich nicht
ausdenken was du
oh mein Gott wie haben die Bastion
zurück gefunden danke da auch für eure
ganzen Kommentare dass ich a bastion und
Festung miteinander verwechselt habe das
hier is ja eine Bastion ich habe das die
ganze Zeit Festung genannt und ich suche
eigentlich eine Festung hier vorne ist
mein Portal da sind jetzt auf jeden Fall
wieder angekommen ich habe jetzt ehrlich
sogar gesagt garnicht mal so damit ist
mir recht ich kann gar kein Deutsch ne
wie du geht paar Minütchen und ich bin
jetzt schon am verzweifeln ich wollte
sagen dass ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
damit gerechnet hätte dass wir so
schnell unser Portal hier zurück finden
deswegen werde ich jetzt noch einmal
dieser Höhlen map eine Chance geben
indem ich mich hier vorne ein bisschen
weiter fortbewegen um einfach zu schon
wieder
in die Hand nehmen
dann können wir versuchen zu töten
tschüss
[Musik]
du kannst dich
das ist jetzt nicht wahr
dass es nicht war
da mal bin ich gerade dumm das ist eine
Festung
das ist ein
das ist ein Fest und wir gerade entdeckt
haben Freunde ich glaubs nicht ich bin
einfach nur wirklich ecc auf meiner
Minimap da unten rechts ist mein Portal
und hier vorne ist wirklich wieder eine
Festung wir haben direkt
wir haben direkt wieder an unserem Spawn
eine Festung
[Musik]
ich muss mich nur irgendwie dahin bauen
können wir vorne sind auf jeden Fall ne
Menge los die mich von allen Seiten
angreifen ich versuche irgendwie
ich habe noch nie so eine beschissene
Neckarfront wie auch immer das Ding hier
heißt erlebt
ich habe weder in Minecraft mit Luka
Staffel 1 noch in Minecraft mit Luka
Staffel 2 bisher so eine folge erlebt
bzw so einen folgen start erlebt wie die
heutige meine lieben Freunde ich bau
mich jetzt einfach mal ganz vorsichtig
da ist er wieder der kommt halt nicht
runter oder oh
mein Gott
[Musik]
Alter ich hätte ihm zugetraut dass er
hier vorne runter Hüfte
[Musik]
wir sind nun allerdings die oben
angekommen
oh mein Gott sind
jetzt erstmal ein bisschen auf
die rechte Seite
[Musik]
aus deren habe ich keine Angst
wieder beschossen Leute ich will einfach
nur Lohn roten bekommen damit ich mir so
einen verdammten Tisch machen kann also
hier vorne sind wir gerade hoch gekommen
deswegen habe ich mich jetzt mal einfach
bis hierhin vorgebaut mit den Fackeln
einfach Selbstbewusstsein Luca hier
vorne lang laufen dann schauen wir mal
ob wir hier vielleicht schon direkt
Kisten haben oder vielleicht doch einen
wo mein Gott hier ist direkt ein Spawner
ich weiß allerdings nicht warum der da
so komisch eingebautes ich mache uns
hier vorne erstmal einen sicheren Weg
rüber und das wäre auch einfach ganz
entspannt rüber laufen können er ist
auch nur das Geld drin ich baue jetzt
mal hier vorne die Zäune ab mal schauen
ob ich jetzt
natürlich
ich kann ja einfach schlagen und ich
kann nichts tun
Alter von
Sponsoren die komme ich jetzt halt nicht
gerade
wieder die Fackeln hier nur auf die
linke Seite setzen sodass wir wissen von
wo wir gekommen sind die Sache ist
einfach meine lieben Freunde ich weiß
nicht
[Musik]
dass er nur
sonst ist die glaube ich niemand da
vorne
und sie hat angegriffen das heißt ich
habe jetzt kurze Zeit um sie zu boxen
und sie hat keine Lohn Route gedroppt
davon sind wieder widder Skelett und
auch noch mehr von den Teilen Alter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich glaube meine lieben Freunde ich lade
diese Folge ich einfach mal uncut hoch
bzw werde ich Text schon ein paar
Schnitte gesetzt haben aber mehr oder
weniger lade ich das Ding gerade
wirklich uncut hoch
es kann doch nicht sein.
[Musik]
es kann doch wirklich nicht sein dass
das hier alles abgeht
ich hör auch schon wieder diesen dummen
Vogel aber ich will einfach alles
auslöschen sodass ich weiß von wo ich
gekommen und dass ich weiß wo ich
[Musik]
du kannst dir das nicht ausdenken ne
die Sache ist allerdings dass ich mich
hier weiterhin darauf konzentrieren
Iserlohn zum Schütten Zack und zack die
ist tot und ich habe eine lohenrute ok
perfekt ich kann ich auch zu lohenstaub
machen und damit kann ich jetzt endlich
anfangen mit dem braun und mit Lohn habe
ich auch generell ganz ganz viele
weitere neue Möglichkeiten ich werde
jetzt allerdings erst mal nach hier
vorne gehen und euch jetzt eine ganz
fixe timelapse einblenden wie ich mich
hier
[Musik]
ihr müsst doch überlegen ich habe es in
dieser Staffel Minecraft mit Luca so
eingestellt dass mein Screen
deutlich dunkler ist und dass ich in
Höhlen deutlich mehr ausleuchten muss
weil ich auf YouTube gesehen habe dass
wir Leute da Freitag schauen dass man
fast gar nichts erkennt ich hatte
Minecraft immer auf der hellsten
Helligkeit allerdings habe ich in dieser
Staffel so eingestellt dass es nicht
sonderlich hättet also für euch
vielleicht leicht schon
entsprechend worauf ich dieses Video
hier gerade guckt die Sache ist
allerdings das ist für mich gerade
extrem düster ist deswegen nehme ich
auch auf den Höhen Situation oder hier
in der Hölle meine Fackel in der Hand
weil ich mich einfach nicht richtig
konzentrieren kann weil ich einfach
nicht richtig gucken kann und weil ich
auch oft meine Augen so zu machen muss
damit ich überhaupt irgendein bisschen
was erkenne ich es auch schon wieder
weiter
in der kompletten Staffel Minecraft mit
Luka
eins
hatten wir glaube ich ein oder zwei oder
Skelette und allein in dieser Folge
hatten wir
10-15
[Musik]
was geht hier ab
diese Folge ist Action pur
[Musik]
es tut mir leid dass ich gar nicht
soviel kommentieren kann allerdings muss
ich nicht so doll hier darauf
konzentrieren dass hiervon nicht von
irgendwo noch ein wither Skelett kommt
noch eine Lohe
[Musik]
und dann noch diese Lex zwischendurch
wegen diesem ganzen Modifikation die ich
mir hier installiert habe
an jeder Ecke an jeder Ecke wartet eine
Lore
und wir haben die Kiste
[Musik]
es war ja so klar
hier ist niemand mehr ganz zu Ende oh
mein Gott
Leute
mein Herz ist auf 180
ich werde mir noch mal ganz kurz
angucken was ich in dieser Truhe hier
befindet allerdings nur Gold und
eiserner rossharnisch
[Musik]
ich bin ganz ehrlich mit euch hatte
heute den total stressigen Tag ich kann
das hier nicht noch weiter aufnehmen es
war von Anfang bis Ende dieser 16
Minuten Aufnahmezeit nur Action
ich werde mir jetzt eine Ofenkartoffel
reinschauen
und hier bin ich ja einigermaßen sicher
und dann geht's genau hier in der
nächsten Folge Minecraft mit Luca
übermorgen weiter wenn ihr Tipps habt
dafür was ich hier noch machen soll wie
ich mich vielleicht verhalten soll
irgendwelche Tricks dann schreibst du
mir gerne und in die Kommentare lasst
ein Daumen hoch unter dem Video hier da
wenn es euch gefallen hat abonniert
meinen Kanal und kriegt auf die
glocke.de noch keinen Teller lucrew seid
ich bin am Ölen
bis morgen bei dem neuen Video ich hoffe
[Musik]